انا باتكلم على ازمه كبيره بتمر بالعالم
ولها تاثير كبير جدا على دول كثير من
العالم اللي ما كانش كل دول العالم انا
باتكلم تحديدا هنا على الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
وبوجه النداء
من اجل ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
من فضلكم
نحن
كدول
اقتصادها
مش قوي
عن الكثير جدا من تبعات
ازمه كرونه سنتين
وتحملناها
والان يعاني ايضا من هذه الحرب
العالم كله اتصور انه بيعاني من هذه الحرب
انا باقول ثاني احنا مستعدين انا بنادي
باسمكم وباسمي ان سمحتوا لي بكده
الحرب هذا نداء من مؤتمر هنا ان سمحتوا لي
بكده الدمار
بالمناسبه انا مستعد ومش
مش للبحث عن دور لا والله ولكن من اجل
العمل
يشاركون الرائده احنا مستعدين نتحرك اذا
كان ده ممكن لايقاف هذه الحرب اشكركم
وارجو ان اكون قد اثقلت عليكم